we always wanted a boat strikes in 20 on
console with originally thinking of
PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360 however with
the announcement and subsequent release
of PlayStation 4 and Xbox one we knew
that we could target those platforms and
do so much more with the announcement of
the idea x cos program it meant that now
we could develop and publish just like
we do on PlayStation on xbox platforms
for the very first time strike suit zero
directors cup is really important for us
because as an independent developer what
we've been able to do is take our own
game and instead of just leaving it on
the shelf is actually update improve
listen to the feedback listen to the
critics and do something about it so
with the directors class we structure
the campaign changing the first quarter
of the game so again it's reaction more
quickly and crucially interest racing
with them we've taken the artwork the
upper west and changed a whole lot of it
making it look a wholly better and
taking account of the power that we now
have our house so to address some of the
feedback from our community our critics
it also be recorded some of the voice
acting and replacing or voice actors
overall with these changes and a host of
other improvements throughout game I
think you're kind of strikes at zero
director's cut is the definitive version
basically we restructure up the first
three missions to gently ease people in
which aspect of the game play
so as previously we introduced the
placement destroyed suit and then threw
them into this intense multi capital
ship battle which was amazing um still
have us racing we now leave a chance to
get to learn how to transform how big a
flux after reduction and this gives
pleasure much easier right into
understanding construction workers
strengths weaknesses our best using
so that in love small conversations
seems to the game of the standout story
join the dots between the characters and
research that you're in this situation
these were alluding to before but now
things are alright solicit and mushy GC
in our film directors cavities small
elements of the health hopefully make a
better stirrup we've put a lot of effort
into improving the look of strikes in
Syria form of the director's cut we
particularly focused on improving the
lip of the ships we've removed pretty
much all the ships from scratch this
time starring a lot more Polly's at them
and ditching the old tiling textures for
custom maps we've also adjusted the art
style slightly this time we're bringing
in more realistic military and
industrial references hopefully you pick
up a modern-day Navy feel for the you
any chips and the Colonials should feel
a bit more commercial big corporation so
we've also added image based lighting to
the engine which allows us to have nice
reflections for polished surfaces giving
our metal more naturalistic look one of
my favorite visual updates are the
modeling comp is completely fine which
really helped communicate scale
throughout the game as a third as always
there's always things want to go back
and change there's always things that
feel didn't quite get right especially
when you're the balloons of time to get
I think things like it's easy to take an
adaptation of the game to new platform
as a port as a version of the same thing
I think we found it as a way to resolve
this disused address concerns that we
had really found on the fourth as a
result it's it's been great we've been
able to polish the game we love and
improve it so as you may have heard born
ready games has flooded over Christmas
Christmas Eve knee height brown water
came in the offices and did a lot of
damage it destroyed computer's power
network everything that was downstairs
and on the floor was pretty much ruined
however a lot of the guys came in and we
worked really hard throughout the period
of the Christmas holidays to get the
place up and running personally for me
and some of the other guys we had
personal items now the office I have a
shelf full of toys some fellas didn't
have these kinds of things and on the
shelf with some really nice books some
star wars book some art books all kinds
of things I've collected over the years
and also a really nice box of my old
collectible card games star wars battle
tear pledging replied these really nice
things which although insurance cover
some things here some things are just
irreplaceable however that hard work
meant when we were able to move all the
guys upstairs for much smaller space
we're able to create an ad hoc network
get enough power enough desk together
but crucially get back on
co-directors park there's plenty more
cool things to talk about going on here
are already games so please do check
back often and thank you for watching